i made my choice
i'm done running
welcome to your weekly ticket
the time has finally come after over two
years since we last saw a marvel movie
on the big screen
black widow is opening in theaters this
friday
and fandango correspondent naz perez
caught up with stars
scarlett johansson and florence pugh who
shared
what it was like to work on the
female-centric film
how does it feel to you guys to be a
part of this project because this is the
most
female-centered mcu movie i think i've
ever seen you know that was our goal
when we really looked at okay what do we
alright we don't we don't
have to tell this story we are we're
telling it because we want to
okay so that's really liberating it's
daunting in some ways but it gives you
all this free reign and it would be we'd
be amiss if we didn't
reflect on what's happening in the
zeitgeist and
you know how empowering it is for women
to be lifting each other up out of
a situation and you know and
strengthening one another and supporting
one another i mean there's definitely
another version of this
that would be the you know movie that we
probably would have made 10 years ago
which is like
you know two women facing off to gain
power
and you know that's not how women
react to one another or relate to one
another how much more interesting is
this story
um you know to really see uh
women coming out the other side as
survivors from some shared traumatic
experience that
you know they they both or they all have
you know have had to face and uh and
something that's been holding them back
that they can now move forward
from like that's just incredible you
know that we were able to
um be in a place where the studio would
support that message
you know it's it's it's been a long
journey to get here and it's exciting to
know that that's
that we will we're never going to be
looking backwards it's just going to be
moving
forward i was just gazing at her and
nodding the entire way through yeah
exactly
like um i don't know i think my
from my perspective coming on board
something
this um bold but also this female
is such a luxury that it's kind of going
hand in hand with it then being a
massive
movie that lots of women and men will go
and watch
um and you know it tackles
so many subjects and in such a
a wonderful way where you really can't
look away from it and you have to listen
it's all information that you can
swallow and you can digest and you can
also
enjoy this movie about family and about
these two sisters
so yeah i'm just i'm just incredibly
grateful that
uh kate shortland directed it that
scarlett is obviously
at the lead and produced it um
and we really had so many amazing women
on set
also guiding this film into the right
direction
um and so even though it's obviously
really cool
it's a big marvel superhero film i think
if you took that away
it would still be just as impressive
and that's that's really exciting and
florence also shared her excitement over
her character's introduction
into the mcu it was
crazy that i even got the job and then
crazy that i was even on set and then
crazy that we even rapped
um and then you know we we were about to
release the film and then
um the pandemic happened and so there
was just there's just been a lot of like
this uh stop start is this real
or is this surreal um and i feel
really excited now to show people what
we made two years ago
um because you know i watched the movie
uh the last week and um
even though it's on my laptop and my
laptop doesn't go very loud i was just
so
impressed and so excited and so like
i was so happy that i loved the film and
i would have loved the film
whether i was going to the cinema and i
had nothing to do with it like i was
just so proud of it
um and the fact that this is my first
you know
here i am uh welcome to the mcu i was
just
uh so amazed with with all the work that
we put in
and and just how enjoyable it was to
watch
in theaters this week is black widow
i'm done running for my past
[Applause]
natasha romanov aka black widow
confronts
the darker parts of her ledger when a
dangerous conspiracy with ties to her
past
arises pursued by a force that will stop
at
nothing to bring her down natasha must
deal with her history as a spy
and the broken relationships left in her
wake long before
she became an avenger the film is
directed by
australian filmmaker kate shortland
and available to watch on voodoo is love
type d
and the sparks brothers are you brothers
we are brothers how did you first meet
we're brothers
music at its best you hear it you go oh
my god what is that
it's insane but it's fantastic edgar
wright's debut documentary the sparks
brothers features commentary from
celebrity fans
flea beck jack antonoff and more
and takes audiences on a musical odyssey
through five weird and wonderful decades
with brothers and bandmates ron and
russell male
celebrating the inspiring legacy of
sparks
your favorite band's favorite band
alright that's it for today but leave us
a comment and let us know what
you'll be watching this week until next
time i'm nikki novak
[Music]
you